bonjour à tous bienvenue dans parlement
hebdo les temps forts de l'actualité
politique et parlementaire en 45 minutes
avec michaël szames elle bonjour katia
bonjour michael et c'est une semaine
sous le signe de l'environnement avec le
coup d'envoi de la coop 21 les grands de
ce monde ont retrouvé françois hollande
au bourget près de paris au chevet du
climat à la france veut faire de ce
rendez vous une réussite dans la lutte
contre le changement climatique n'est
pas facile de satisfaire les intérêts de
tous les critiques de plus en plus vives
contre l'état d'urgence bernard
cazeneuve dépensons dispositif
d'exception annonce la fermeture de
quatre mosquées les défenseurs des
libertés individuelles et certains
parlementaires dénoncent quelques
dérives et puis c'était donc que les
derniers jours de campagne pour les
élections régionales les candidats ont
jeté leurs dernières forces dans la
bataille le front national est en tête
des intentions de vote
you national au premier tour front
républicain ou pas contre le fn les
parties se divise notre invité cette
semaine pour commenter toute cette
actualité david rachline bonjour bonjour
vous êtes sénateur du front national
maire de fréjus sénateur du var vous
allez commenter toute cette actualité et
on va commencer bien évidemment par la
caf et l environnement l'environnement
et lundi 150 chefs d'état et de
gouvernement qui se réunissent à paris
pour le coup d'envoi de la coop
c'est donc parti pour quinze jours de
débat sur le climat les grands de ce
monde ont posé aux côtés de françois
hollande pour la photo de famille et
puis les discours se sont succédé à la
tribune xhaka promettant des mesures
pour éviter un réchauffement de la
planète à + 2 degrés il faut trouver un
accord contraignant a martelé françois
hollande écoutez je ne pose pas à la
lutte contre le terrorisme à la lutte
contre le réchauffement climatique
ce sont deux grands défis mondiaux que
deux devons relever parce que nous
devons laisser à nos enfants
davantage qu'un monde libéré de la
terreur nous leur devons une planète
préservée des catastrophes
une planète viable est ce que pour vous
david rachline un françois hollande a
pris un risque politique en organisant
et en maintenant cette coop 21 s'il n'y
a pas d'accord contraignant
je crois qu'il est dans son rôle de
président de la république et que c'est
une initiative qui est plutôt positive à
l'évidence le véritable problème c'est
qu'un certain nombre de grands débats
urgents ne sont pas abordées dans le
cadre de cette grande réunion des chefs
d'état le post le patriotisme économique
les circuits courts le fait que
aujourd'hui à cause du mondialisme à
cause de l'idéologie prônée par les
grands de ce monde ont produit à des
milliers de kilomètres de là où l'on
consommé on retraite ces mêmes produits
encore plus loin de la télé libre
échange ce que j'appelle le livre est
une chose à réaliser absolument qu'ils
sont de véritables dangers pour notre
pays pour son économie pour notre
société mais aussi pour l'écologie non
seulement françaises n'ont vraiment mais
aussi pour l'écologie mondiale et ce
sont des sujets qui ne sont pas abordés
je le regrette parce que je pense que ça
apporterait vraiment au débat demandé en
fait un nouveau modèle économique c'est
ça absolument il faut le réformer de
fond en comble notre modèle c'est
clairement le patriotisme économique
c'est le fait de produire plus pressée
de favoriser les circuits courts en
faire écouter dans un certain nombre de
nos cantines on mange des produits qui
sont fabriqués à plusieurs milliers de
kilomètres ça n'a aucun sens il faut
évidemment faire en sorte de travailler
de faire travailler d'abord nos
agriculteurs par exemple dans ce domaine
là de faire travailler nos entreprises
les favoriser dans le cadre des marchés
publics
c'est vrai au niveau des régions mais ça
devrait être le cas aussi au niveau de
l'état et des grandes entreprises telles
que la sncf qui attribue des marchés
quelquefois des entreprises qui ne sont
pas des entreprises françaises
je le regrette ces nouveaux ce discours
au front national vous êtes converti au
vert mais pas du tout écouter vous avez
la gentillesse de me poser la question
donc je vous y répondre mais je n'aurais
pu vous répondre exactement la même
chose il ya plusieurs années déjà
c'est vrai alors par exemple quand on va
dans le nord-pas-de-calais comme marine
le pen se remet à proposer ce fameux
projet canal seine nord qu'elle avait
refusé en 2010 et aujourd'hui elle dit
c'est très bien c'est parfait c'est
exactement ce qu'il fallait faire moi je
suis pas posé question comme si vous a
pas échappé que j'étais sénateur varois
j'ai compris ce n'est pas spécialiste de
ces questions mais je sais que
j'obtienne un vrai changement marine le
pen s'adapte à la situation locale
il y à des évolutions permanentes dans
ces régions il faut tenir compte
évidemment où vous adapter évidemment
que nous adaptons nous sommes un
mouvement politique qui vit avec son
temps qu'ils s'adaptent et nos
propositions doivent coller avec le réel
et je crois que même nous sommes les
seuls à nous adapter véritablement à ses
grandes évolutions de notre temps elle
va changer un petit peu de sujet mardi
le premier ministre reçoit les
parlementaires et au menu de cette
réunion qu'il veut hebdomadaire un point
régulier sur l'état d'urgence qui est de
plus en plus critiqués on entend très
souvent ces derniers temps le pré
ministre a tenu à rassurer les
parlementaires voient tout cela avec une
jennifer se mais le gouvernement s'y
était engagé les parlementaires ont été
reçus tout à l'heure pour faire le point
perquisitions arrestations modification
de la constitution et surtout état
d'urgence
manuel valls envisager ce matin une
prolongation au-delà du 26 février
du côté du groupe socialiste les
sénateurs approuvent dans les jours qui
viennent et j'ai affirmé au nom de mon
groupe que si pour des raisons
de l'enquêté pour les besoins de la
lutte contre le terrorisme
il fallait que l'état d'urgence soit
éventuellement prolongé en février sous
réserve de ces précisions le groupe
socialiste et républicain du sénat
soutiendraient le gouvernement dans la
prolongation de l'état d'urgence
pour les républicains s'étaient à
d'urgence décrétée le 13 novembre est
elle nécessaire mais ne doit pas déroger
aux principes de l'état de droit la
lutte contre le terrorisme c'est la
priorité absolue mais elle n'autorise
pas toutes les méthodes il faut donc que
même dans le cadre de l'état d'urgence
le droit soit respecté sous le contrôle
du juge que ce soit le conseil d'état où
le juge judiciaire
le sénat sera en première ligne une
mission de suivi de l'état d'urgence
piloté par l'ancien garde des sceaux
michel mercier va débuter ses travaux le
9 décembre elle auditionnera notamment
ce jour là le procureur de paris
françois molins parmi les mesures
prévues par l'état d'urgence la sinne il
ya donc l'assignation résident certains
militants écologistes en ont fait les
frais ce qui a provoqué la colère de
noël mamère bernard cazeneuve du coût a
défendu son arsenal devant la
représentation nationale écoutez je ne
veux pas je ne peux pas accepter que les
forces de sécurité aujourd'hui puissent
se prendre en charge dans l'espace
public
des casseurs je ne l'accepterai jamais
et tous ceux qui l'acceptent sur ses
bancs dont monsieur mamère qui s'agitent
sont dans l'irresponsabilité totale et
je tiens à le dire très clairement ici
pour ce qui concerne les militants
écologistes y en a eu aucun d'assigner
ceux qui ont été assignés ce sont des
individus violents
qu'il continue à jouer les hypocrites
qu'il continue son discours schizophrène
mais moi je n'ai pas à répondre à ce
monsieur
alors avant d'évoquer réunion de
matignon est ce que et qu'est-ce que
vous que vous avez vu que cet échange
entre bernard cazeneuve et noël manas
que bernard cazeneuve a eu raison de
réponse qu'il a écouté le gouvernement a
fait le choix comme il l'avait fait
après les événements du mois de janvier
de montrer ses muscles et laissez nous
faire croire à une prise de conscience
véritable de la situation tant mieux si
un certain nombre de mesures sont prises
c'est éminemment positif le problème
c'est que il faudrait qu'on passe de la
parole aux actes
parce que la réalité dans ce pays c'est
qu'il y à peu près 80 mosquées
salafistes
on le sait et rien ne se passe pour le
moment on attend toujours
on attend toujours les actes de ce
gouvernement qui c'est vrai communique
beaucoup fait beaucoup de déclarations
ont fait beaucoup de déclarations
tonitruantes et il reçoit les
parlementaires à l'exception des
parlementaires du front national
d'ailleurs à l'exception des
parlementaires des médias nationaux
pas que je sache mais ça n'est pas une
surprise pour nous le savons que le
gouvernement à la démocratie à deux
vitesses mais groupe qui était aussi les
représentants c'est ça c'est ça
bon avec la proportionnelle que nous
rétablirons le problème sera réglé
mais toujours est il que voilà on attend
maintenant des actes parce qu'encore une
fois la communication c'est bien mais la
parole c'est bien mais les actes c'est
mieux
je vous le dis on les attend toujours
pour le moment est ce que vous
souhaiteriez que l'état d'urgence soit
prolongée mais probablement ce sera sera
ce sera nécessaire sans doute fait si on
vous entend bien c'est nécessaire mais
pas formé mais ça n'est pas tellement le
problème le problème c'est le problème
de fond et le problème de fond c'est de
se poser la question des frontières et
de la sortie de l'espace schengen le
problème c'est de se poser la question
générale de l'immigration la question
générale du laxisme pénale que nous
subissons depuis des années qui fait que
quand on est condamné à moins d'un an de
prison aujourd'hui on ne les fait pas
réellement etc
ce sont toutes ces problématiques là qui
aujourd'hui ne sont pas abordées et qui
mettent en danger les français et c'est
ça qui est très inquiétant c'est que les
français aujourd'hui ne sont plus en
sécurité
y compris avec les mesures
malheureusement de ce gouvernement qui
ne sont pas suffisantes
donc pour vous l'état d'urgence est pas
suffisant même si on instaurait jusqu'à
6 mais c'est positif mais ce n'est pas
suffisant car il faut aussi je vous le
dis renvoyer chez eux les imams autant
les imams qui prêchent la haine contre
les valeurs de la république contre la
france toutes ces mosquées salafistes
prise en main par les extrémistes à une
action unie verts dénoncent action hier
je crois quatre mosquées qui ont été
fermées et quatre ou cinq y en a 80 qui
sont répertoriés qu'est ce qu'on attend
pour mettre dehors ou pour déchoir de
leur nationalité les fichiers est ce
dont on sait qu'ils ont de la sympathie
socialisme radical
sachant les riches choix de la
nationalité et puis les expulser ensuite
dans leur pays parce qu'elles n'ont qu'à
rester sur notre territoire ce n'est pas
que symbolique
quand vous expulser des gens qui sont
des terroristes plutôt potentiel alors
vous sécurisez quand même un peu le
territoire
aujourd'hui ça n'est parfait comment se
fait-il qu'ils aient supprimé des
dizaines de milliers de postes dans la
police dans la gendarmerie baisser les
moyens des services de renseignement
aussi bien d'ailleurs sur le
gouvernement de nicolas sarkozy que sous
françois hollande on nous dit
aujourd'hui il va y avoir quelques 10
quelques centaines de postes
supplémentaires créés moi j'appelle à ce
qu'on revienne aux effectifs antérieurs
à la prise de pouvoir par nicolas
sarkozy c'est à dire au moins 13 mois
s'est de plus et donc ça voudrait dire
qu'il faudrait aller bien au delà des
budgets alloués aujourd'hui oui
absolument absolument mais vous
inquiétez pas on peut faire bien des
écoles avec est difficile avec oui alors
ça qu'on veut faire bien des économies
par ailleurs et je crois qu'il ya des
priorités absolues quand il s'agit de
sécurité des français ils attendent les
français qu'on assure leur sécurité
c'est le rôle de l'état
il faut qu'ils la surprise le laisser
filer les déficits mais je vous le dis
je pense que ça n'est pas une question
qui doit être prioritaire on ne négocie
pas avec la sécurité des français
et croyez-moi par ailleurs il y a
beaucoup d'économies à faire justement
son programme économique ait eu pas mal
de réactions cette semaine aurait autour
du programme économique du front
national
la presse régionale les milieux
culturels les syndicats sont montés au
front contre le front national et
notamment pierre gattaz c'est le patron
des patrons russell avec aurélie romaine
à quelques jours du premier tour des
régionales pierre gattaz met le feu aux
poudres
interview dans la presse et enfonce le
clou devant les journalistes mon
problème c'est pas le front national mon
problème c'est la politique économique
du front national qui me rappelle la
politique de l'extrême gauche et qui me
rappelle celle du programme commun de la
gauche de 1981 qui nous a conduits dans
le mur
dans son viseur le programme national du
fn
la sortie de l'euro le retour à la
retraite à 60 ans ou encore la hausse du
smic défié sur son programme économique
la présidente du fn lui répond par sa
meilleure arme l'attak
s'il est si sûr de lui qui viennent
débattre avec moi il ne le veut pas
voilà il ne le veut pas parce qu'il n'a
rien à dire parce que les arguments
qu'il utilise sont des arguments
totalement caricaturaux qui peuvent être
démontée en l'espace de cinq minutes
il se fonde d'ailleurs sur des travaux
qui sont faits par l'ump soit disant des
fondations mais en réalité c'est l'ump
qui est derrière ou par le parti
socialiste
c'est bien ump/ps medef même combat
parfait un amalgame entre les
républicains et le medef que son
président tente de contourner la
retraite à 60 ans l'augmentation du smig
cetera sans faire attention la baisse
des charges la compétitivité et
l'attractivité ça aura un impact sur
l'entreprise et la compétitivité de
l'entreprise sait tous qu'une ce dont je
me qui me kim qui me gêne aujourd'hui je
vais sucre est sûre le parti sur le
programme politique je maîtrise
rapproche économique et pas de politique
mais cette attaque du medef fait suite à
celle de certains journaux locaux du
nord qui se sont positionnés contre une
possible victoire aux régionales de
marine le pen c'est très clair c'est
tous contre vous ce retour de la
victimisation du fromage mais les
habitudes j'essaye de préserver les
places et les postes qui sont les leurs
et qu'ils craignent de perdre à
l'occasion de ces élections régionales
quoi ça veut dire s'il arrive au pouvoir
ou les envoyer mes trois fois pas mais
c'est les français qui vont les renvoyer
pourquoi parce qu'ils ont échoué parce
que la politique qu'il mène depuis des
décennies désormais est catastrophique
on entend des leçons d'économie de la
part de monsieur gattaz et la part des
responsables du parti socialiste il ya
jamais eu autant de chômeurs dans notre
pays que qu'aujourd'hui au moment où on
parle jamais il y à une situation aussi
délétère en matière économique et vous
dites on ne fera pas la faute du logo du
parti socialiste la faute de la droite
tout cas oui la faute des mesures et des
grandes orientations qui ont été prises
par nos élites depuis des dizaines
d'années qui a produit cette situation
et nous les français le savent bien nous
allons nous efforcer au moins de changer
le cap économique de faire en sorte
qu'on intègre le patriotisme économique
qu'on fasse en sorte de privilégier est
d'aider les petites et les moyennes
entreprises certes peut-être pas les
multinationales comme le souhaiterait
monsieur gattaz mais au moins les
petites et les moyennes entreprises qui
créent de l'emploi dans le pays et qui
sont absolument écrasée de charge
aujourd'hui c'est ces gens là que nous
souhaitons aider ils le savent bien
d'ailleurs
mais vous accepté d'entendre certaines
critiques y compris dans mon coeur
voilà non mais tout le monde a tort
sauve ou non on entend on en entend ce
qu'ils disent simplement ce que je
constate c'est que leur politique amené
la france à la ruine a mené à une
situation encore une fois en termes
d'emploi qui est absolument
catastrophique nous expliquer que nous
serions ceux qui l ont aggravé la
situation je crois que c'est une
plaisanterie beurre regarder yanogo
agraire et un sondage monsieur rachline
ifop pour la provence et sud radio ou
dans votre région en région paca 56 %
des interrogés vers un impact négatif
sur l'économie si vous arrivez au
pouvoir avec marion maréchal-le pen
65% des investisseurs étrangers vous
fait peur non mais vous allez je crois
pas du tout que nous fassions peur
d'abord au niveau des élections
régionales
et si nous prenions devient un certain
nombre de régions restons dans le cadre
des compétences pourquoi il nous parle
des sujets nationaux alors qu'on est en
plein dans une élection régionale sanaa
d'abord là on parle de l'intérieur
économique ensuite ensuite les
entrepreneurs ne sont peut-être 51 ou 52
% à croire ce que racontent 56 ça veut
dire qu'il y en a une bonne partie qui
ne ne crois pas 7
cette charge un petit peu tonitruant de
la part de nos adversaires
je crois qu'ils paniquent voilà la
réalité je crois qu'il panique qui sont
en train de caricaturer totalement notre
programme économique car en réalité rien
de ce qu'ils disent n'est conforme à la
réalité de ce que nous souhaitons nous
souhaitons précisément baisser les
charges pour les petites et moyennes
entreprises
essayer de soutenir
l'emploi et l'économie dans notre pays
vous mais jamais par des acteurs
économiques concentré notamment et petit
pack mais évidemment je me suis rendu
d'ailleurs moi même un certain nombre de
salons pour discuter avec ses chefs
d'entreprise qui nous disent les petits
chefs d'entreprise qui nous disent la
concurrence déloyale avec des
entreprises chinoises ou men et autres a
été créée par l'ump est sa a été créée
par ce modèle économique et il faut en
sortir parce qu'il faut aider par
priorité les entreprises de notre pays
qui aujourd'hui sont abandonnés sont
soumises à une concurrence qui n'est pas
supportable
david rachline je disais dit tous contre
vous écoutez ce que disait le premier
ministre nouvelle valse et bâtiments qui
ne montera pas il reculera
si chacun fait son devoir de vacances où
les français vont voter et chacun devra
prendre ses responsabilités à gauche
comme à droite pour empêcher le fonds
national de gagner une région où lui
répondez quoi premier ministre mais je
lui réponds que ce sont les français qui
doivent décider et que monsieur valls
s'il n'est pas d'accord avec ce principe
clair qui est celui de la république et
de la démocratie il faut qu'il change de
régime et qu'ils en fassent en tout cas
la proposition manifestement ils sont
pas aussi démocrates qui veulent bien
dire en refusant que par exemple 20% ou
25% des français peut être 30 demain
soir présenté à l'assemblée nationale où
puissent gérer des collectivités
territoriales comme nous le faisons je
crois que monsieur valls doit s'habituer
à la démocratie doit s'habituer à l'idée
qu'il n'y ait pas que des gens qui
pensent comme lui je pense que ce serait
une bonne chose maintenant c'est aux
français de se déterminer et les
français pour terminer en ont assez de
la magouille électorale entre l'ump
jean-christophe colle à la réalité
magouille électorale à magouilles
électorales la magouille électorale oui
mais parce que c'est la réalité la
magouille électorale c'est ce qui fait
que le choix des français est contournée
par des accords des arrangements mais
pourquoi ne se ne se présente il pas
ensemble dès le premier tour
les choses seraient extrêmement clair là
vous procède par exemple la paca où les
examens des socialistes pourrait se
désister
par exemple parce qu il est bien évident
que si monsieur est rené lemas n'est pas
là si monsieur estrosi pas très loin si
monsieur estrosi était élu avec les voix
de la gauche
il ferait une politique de centre gauche
tout le monde le sait très bien et les
habitants de la paca n'en veulent pas de
cette politique alors que monsieur
estrosi assume ses responsabilités se
présente dès le premier tour avec
monsieur castaner et les français les
habitants de notre région juge
il en est de même pour les autres
régions marine le pen est-il que le fn
est en position d'en porter entre quatre
à cinq régions parle même de 6 est-ce
que c'est ambitieux moi je crois que
c'est une attente de la part des
français que de voir un véritable
changement que de voir qu'il n'est que
la hausse des impôts n'est pas une
fatalité que l'insécurité endémique
telle que nous la connaissons n'est pas
une fatalité que l'absence de
développement économique l'absence
d'aménagement du territoire de formation
parce que nous nous pâtissons cela
concrètement dans le région y compris
les élus d'ailleurs avec l'absence de
projet ambitieux à cause de la
catastrophe socialiste qui agiraient
nous gérons nos régions depuis des
années je crois qu'ils ont soif d'une
alternative que nous proposons ils ont
envie de nous laisser notre chance c'est
une très bonne chose
à mon avis je voudrais vous faire réagir
aux propos de jean christophe cambadélis
qui a dit c'est le retour de vichy
à l'époque c'était contrôlé juste
maintenant c'est contre les musulmans
enfin écoutez ça n'est pas sérieux ça
n'est pas du niveau on sait que monsieur
cambadélis est en difficulté qui sont
partis les son parti va prendre une
claque phénoménal aux élections ne sera
pas la première vous me direz une blague
phénoménal aux élections régionales plus
personne ne croit à ce genre d'argument
pitoyable les gens savent bien que nous
sommes des élus républicains attachés à
défendre nos territoires nous le voyons
bien dans les communes que nous gérons
d'ailleurs que nous exerçons avec
honneur les responsabilités qui nous ont
été confiées et je crois que c'est un
véritable dérapage scandaleux que de
faire de telles accusations très
rapidement il ya une donnée importante
pour ces régionales c'est l'abstention
est ce que vous en avez peur est ce que
vous pensez que ça peut vous servir ou
pas du tout oui moi je craint
l'abstention parce que je suis favorable
à ce que les français soient les plus
nombreuses possibles à se prononcer et
c'est toujours c'est toujours
regrettable quand on est républicain que
de savoir que trop de français sont
dégoûtés par la politique pour un
certain nombre d'entre eux d'ailleurs on
peut les comprendre
parce que ce balancier ump ps ump ps qui
ne change rien qui ne fait que continuer
dans une politique qui même notre pays à
la ruine
on peut courait alors à nous de montrer
à nous de montrer qu'il ya une
alternative possible et à nous de leur
faire croire qu'il est possible de faire
un véritable changement dans ce pays
enfin en attendant je vous propose de
revenir à l'actualité parlementaire
puisque mardi toujours l'assemblée
nationale
adopté le projet de loi de modernisation
du système de santé un texte porté par
marisol touraine qui a suscité qui
suscite depuis des mois la polémique et
l'opposition d'une majorité de médecins
notamment la mesure qui instaure la
généralisation du tiers payant
david rachline cette mesure est elle
pour vous une mesure de justice sociale
la santé pour tous se tient je crois que
c'est une mesure dangereuse les
professionnels de santé se sont
mobilisés je crois que le gouvernement
ne tient absolument pas compte des
réalités de notre pays des réalités des
professionnels qui les alertent pourtant
sur ce dossier là mais aussi sur
beaucoup d'autres on s'en prend tantôt
médecin tantôt au notaire tantôt aux uns
et aux autres
je crois que c'est un véritable danger
parce que ce sont des secteurs
professionnels qui ont besoin de l'aide
du gouvernement qui ont besoin de l'être
des parlementaires ou aujourd'hui on va
les affaiblir je crois que c'est
extrêmement dangereux
je vous propose de passer au mercredi on
parlait de l'état d'urgence mais encore
parler un tout petit peu l'état
d'urgence est sous surveillance au
parlement le sénat comme l'assemblée
nationale vont le surveiller de très
près les deux commissions des lois ont
annoncé qu'elle allait mettre en place
ce qu'on appelle une veille
parlementaire les détails avec thibault
le floch
c'était une condition sinequanone pour
les parlementaires pouvoir contrôler en
temps réel l'action du gouvernement sous
l'état d'urgence
pour cela jean jacques urvoas propose
que la commission des lois dispose
pendant trois mois des mêmes pouvoirs
qu'une commission denquête toute
personne dont nous jugerons l'audition
utile sera tenue de déférer à la
convocation de la commission des lois
tous les renseignements de nature à
faciliter notre mission devront nous
être fournie
nous serons ainsi habilité à nous faire
communiquer tous les documents de
service et les parlementaires vont avoir
du travail
au vu des chiffres dévoilés par bernard
cazeneuve après quasiment trois semaines
d'application de l'état d'urgence nous
avons procédé à 2235 perquisition depuis
le début de l'état d'urgence c'est vers
qu'ils y sion ont permis deux cent
soixante trois interpellés
sion qui ont conduit à 232 garde à vue
ce que nous voulons savoir c'est si
toutes ces perquisitions sont vraiment
justifié il faut qu'on puisse avoir des
remontées précise on a ouvert un site
pour cela pour contrôler pour vérifier
la justification de cette acquisition le
suivi de l'enquète des parlementaires
est à retrouver sur le site internet de
l'assemblée nationale avant la
publication d'un rapport parlementaire
dans trois mois je pensais bien qu'il
veut mettre sous surveillance de la part
des parlementaires c'est le travail sur
steam c'est le travail c'est le travail
des parlementaires que de surveiller
l'état d'urgence qu'est ce que vous avez
l'impression qu'à des dérives pas de la
part de l'état pas de la part du
gouvernement
keira de la part des services de police
j'ai vu en revanche devrait dérives de
la part d'un certain nombre de
mouvements d'extrême gauche qui n'ont
pas hésité à saccager un certain nombre
d'endroits y compris de souvenirs dans
les rues de paris au moment de la coop
21 avec des manifestations absolument
scandaleuse que l'état n'a pas été
capable de juguler ce qui en dit long
sur l'inquiétante situation que nous
vivons ouvriers de surveillance et les
omis manifestement c'est manifestement
ce n'est pas suffisant et moi je crois
qu'il faut dissoudre ces mouvements
extrémistes qui mettent à feu et à sang
un certain nombre de nos communes
il faudrait qu'on puisse quitter ta
gorge les dissoudre ou témoin état
d'urgence ou non il faut dissoudre ce
genre d'organisations extrémistes qui
met en péril la sécurité des français
comme on l'a vu encore ces jours ci
c'est clair est ce que vous pensez qu'il
est possible d'instaurer ce contrôle en
temps réel que réclament les
parlementaires quand il s'agit de
mesures exceptionnelles comme l'état
d'urgence vous il aussi le contrôle est
compatible wii mais moi je crois que ce
contrôle est utile je crois que ce
contrôle est utile que les partenaires
et les parlementaires qui sont les
représentants des français doivent
savoir ce qu'il se passe exactement ça
ne veut pas dire que l'état doit leur
demander l'autorisation systématiquement
faut qu'ils aient un équilibre qui se
crée mais le contrôle est utile
maintenant encore une fois
ça n'est pas vraiment le sujet est le
véritable sujet c'est que qu'attend le
gouvernement pour aller plus loin plus
vite plus fort pour rétablir la sécurité
dans notre pays pour l'instant on en est
loin puisque je vous rappelle que rien
n'a été fait je vous le disais tout à
l'heure ni sur l'immigration les trois
millions de migrants annoncé par l'union
européenne par la commission européenne
vont-ils venir sur le territoire comme
c'était prévu puisque le gouvernement
n'a pas réagi sur ce sujet voilà on
attend des réponses maintenant précise
on les attend toujours par rapport aux
groupes aux personnes très régaliens
radicaliser qui font l'objet de fiches s
vous proposez quoi de plus la déchéance
de la nationalité pour les binationaux
c'est la gauche qui ne propose va être
fait donc ça n'est pas fait on attend
toujours a passé sa part m a tant déçu
non mais y'a pas du tout besoin et alors
là je vous le dis clairement il n'y a
pas de besoin du tout d'une réforme
contribue pour le faire ça fait
maintenant quinze jours trois semaines
qu'on attend qu'ils le fassent pourquoi
ne le font-ils paris aujourd'hui c'est
la question que je pose comment se
fait-il qu'on soit encore obligé d'abord
avant de déchoir de leur nationalité ces
fichiers avant de sortir de schengen et
de rétablir véritablement des avances de
fermer les mots c'est ça la pensée que
ça elles sont au nombre de 80 sur notre
territoire et qui sont encore ouverts
que ça va passer leur sort et de ce
qu'on attend c'est sam accusés l'ont
mêlée et les gens se radicalise aussi
c'est le cédant des dans des lieux qui
sont autres que les mosquées parce
qu'ils savent qu'ils sont très
surveillées c'est sûrement vous le savez
bien
et quand sert d'ailleurs il faut que
c'est ailleurs que rendre leurs moyens
aux services de renseignement dans notre
de notre pays pour qu'ils puissent faire
un travail efficace c'est l'essentiel le
renseignement dans ces domaines là il
faut donc que le gouvernement alloue des
moyens supplémentaires à nos services de
renseignement et puis une fois qu'on a
des gens écoutent et j'étais sur un
plateau la dernière fois où une
responsable du parti socialiste me
disais oui mais l'avantagé avec les
fichiers fc ou qu'au moins on peut les
surveiller m'enfin entre temps parfois
ils font des attentats et donc il faut
prendre un certain nombre de mesures
pour les mettre hors du pacifique
aujourd'hui on ne fait pas non parce que
quand leurs liens avec l'islamisme
radical est avérée il faut les mettre
hors d'état de nuire en prison où les
expériences ils sont étrangers en amont
bien sûr avant qu'il fasse des attentats
si possible je vous propose de quitter
un petit peu l'état d'urgence pour
quelques
c'est en tout cas parler de tout autre
chose les enfants de chômeurs
peuvent-ils être privés de cantine c'est
la question que se pose en tout cas
certaines municipalités qui ne réserve
pas de restauration scolaire aux élèves
dont les parents travaillent une
proposition de loi pour lutter contre
cette pratique a été rejeté par le sénat
les explications de matériaux à la
cantine pour tous ce n'est pas encore
pour tout de suite
en tout cas au sénat ce matin la
commission a donné un avis défavorable
au texte visant à garantir l'accès de
tous les enfants dans les cantines
certaines communes refusent les enfants
de chômeurs faute de place ou par souci
d'économie la priorité est donc donnée
aux enfants des parents qui travaillent
un fonctionnement discriminatoire que
dénonce david assouline
il faut absolument la république une
indivisible sur ces principes
fondamentaux le principe fondamental de
l'égalité d'accès
là c'est pas le c'est pas un enfant
c'est c'est pas une question de mérite
c'est pas une question comportement
c'est une question on le refuse pour des
raisons financières et des enfants selon
qui les parents qu'ils aient les moyens
ou pas vont être jetés
on ne dispose d'aucun chiffre officiel
sur les communes concernées
la dernière enquête date de 2011 du
journal le monde
37 communes restreignant l'accès à la
restauration collective sur des critères
parentaux ils étaient recensés mais pour
la droite il est inutile de légiférer
sur ce sujet il ya des communes qui
n'ont pas la possibilité financière de
le faire ça serait de donner un mauvais
signal aux communes de les obliger de
faire cela je crois que c'est un faux
problème c'est un faux débat c'est
encore le débat politique d'hier
certains partis politiques ont du coeur
d'eau dans nos pages crois que ces
passages pour ça c'est une prise de
position réaliste aujourd'hui ce texte
est inutile
il est d'une grande générosité au départ
mais il est dangereux finalement parce
que ben les maires en a un peu ras le
bol une proposition de loi qui a été
adoptée par l'assemblée au mois de mars
le texte sera discuté en décembre au
sénat vera lynn cette pratique at elle
eu lieu chez vous à fréjus nous est le
maire écoutez le véritable problème
aujourd'hui c'est que les collectivités
territoriales sont dans de traverse une
période particulièrement difficile parce
que l'état a passé son temps ces
dernières années aussi bien d'ailleurs
sur nicolas sarkozy ou françois hollande
à faire des économies sur le dos des
collectivités territoriales si bien
qu'elles sont en grande difficulté et
que s'explique on ne met pas les enfants
la cantine et que parfois quand il n'y a
plus de place on soit obligé de refuser
un certain sur deux personnes sur des
critères mais il est bien évident que si
on avait la place nécessaire en
accepterait l'ensemble des élèves en
tout cas moi si la place est disponible
alors je ne fais pas de distinction
entre les uns et les autres répète
l'accession c'est la pratique mais
athènes du genre mais en revanche en
revanche mais ce qui est certain c'est
qu'on ne peut pas passer son temps à
exiger toujours davantage que la part
des mairies de la part des collectivités
territoriales sont leurs données les
finances les propositions de monsieur
assouline pourquoi pas accueillir tout
le monde au sein de cantine mais qu'il
nous donne les moyens pour le faire
aujourd'hui ils passent leur temps la
ville de fréjus c'est un million cinq de
dotation en moins chaque année
est ce que vous vous rendez compte la
difficulté dans la économique et
financière budgétaire dans laquelle nous
sommes aujourd'hui avec les rythmes
scolaires qui ont coûté quatre cent
mille euros pour une commune de 50000
habitants ça fait déjà 2 millions
d'euros de la seule responsabilité de
l'état s'il nous donne les moyens pour
prépare pour parfaire notre politique
j'allais dire et à ce moment là nous le
ferons dès lors l air les républicains
qui disent pas une question de coeur ou
pas mais non de l'argent c'est les
questions budgétaires évidemment aussi
l'ensemble des municipalités pouvait
accueillir l'ensemble des élèves on
serait les premiers avis mais chez vous
c'est lorsque je crois qu'il n'y a pas
de problématique avec cela dans la ville
en tout cas aujourd'hui je crois qu'on
accueille tous ceux qui le souhaitent en
revanche et je comprends qu'il y ait des
petites communes dans lesquelles n'y ait
pas de salle suffisamment grande ou deux
possibilités budgétaires de l'accueillir
davantage alors que l'état nc collecter
ces collectivités et à ce moment là on
en reparlera aujourd'hui ça n'est pas le
cas il faut arrêter d'en demander
toujours davantage aux collectivités
alors on revient aux questions
parlementaires parce que jeudi il est
question de révision de la constitution
on en parlait le lien instant le projet
de révision constitutionnelle sera donc
présenté en conseil des ministres 23
décembre la veille du réveillon de noël
il sera auparavant examiné par le
conseil d'état ce texte doit consolider
l'état d'urgence il prévoit également la
déchéance de nationalité
stéphanie des pierres à l'heure actuelle
l'état d'urgence est régi par une loi de
1955 avec la révision constitutionnelle
ses modalités d'instauration ne change
pas ce sera toujours par décret
présidentiel
selon le projet du gouvernement la
constitution ne donne pas de durée
maximale pour l'état d'urgence c'est
toujours la loi qui on fixera la durée
en revanche les mesures administratives
qui en découlent ne pourront pas
s'exercer au delà de six mois
à droite comme à gauche les députés se
prépare un long combat contre le
terrorisme
à l'évidence la menace terroriste
islamiste qui est très élevé aujourd'hui
elle sera encore très élevé le 26
février au moment où l'état d'urgence
expirera est-ce qu'il faut prolonger
l'état d'urgence débat comptes devra
voir dans les semaines à venir
à l'évidence on aura encore besoin de
moyens opérationnels juridique pour les
préfets pour les policiers parmi les
autres mesures figurant dans le projet
de révision constitutionnelle la
déchéance de nationalité
elle existe déjà pour les binationaux
qui ont acquis la nationalité française
elle sera étendue aux binationaux qui
sont nés français
d'ores et déjà cette idée fait bondir
une partie de la gauche
c'est une première entaille au droit du
sol franchement je vous le dis je ne
pensais pas que la gauche serait capable
de faire ça c'est non seulement
insupportable mais c'est indigne de ce
que la gauche a porté pendant tant
d'années
le débat sera pas de savoir son martyre
au terrorisme pas le débat sera de
savoir si quand on a un binational est
vraiment en français c'est ce que
l'extrême droite nous serine depuis des
années aux bisontins
donc si nous on met le doigt dans cet
engrenage s'arrêtera pas pour sa
production
le gouvernement devrait présenter sa
réforme constitutionnelle en conseil des
ministres le 23 décembre et au parlement
en janvier pour être adopté elle doit
être votée par les trois cinquièmes des
parlementaires
vous avez de la chance vous interroger
sur la révision constitutionnelle je
vous présente jim jarrassé bonjour m
notre partenaire je vais vous poser
quelques questions d'autres masters iv
voilà alors d'abord sur cette révision
constitutionnelle dont projet de loi
présenté en conseil des ministres avant
la fin de l'année ensuite au mois de
janvier ce que vous êtes prêts à aller
au congrès a voté cette révision
constitutionnelle chandon attendons de
savoir ce qu'il y aura concrètement dans
cette réforme
déjà les maisons encore une fois il
m'apparaît que c'est beaucoup de
communication on discute beaucoup on
parle beaucoup
ce qui fait réagir d'ailleurs aussi la
gauche on voit que certains ne sont même
pas prêt à assurer la sécurité des
français y compris dans les amis actuels
du gouvernement dans ce qu'ils le
soutiennent on l'a lu à l'instant
la réalité c'est qu'il ya un certain
nombre de mesures je les ai évoqué tout
à l'heure qu'il faudrait prendre
immédiatement on ne les prend pas on
attend de faire encore davantage de
communication
tout ça est bien gentil mais ça ne
sécurise pas notre pays je reviens
l'instant sur la question de la
binationalité d'ailleurs on entendait
noël mamère ou un autre député qui
parlait de la fin du droit du sol
oui ça serait la fin du droit du sol non
mais d'abord je crois pas que ce soit la
fin du droit du sol moi je suis partisan
de la fin du droit du sol ça serait déjà
les partisans d'une réforme de la
nationalité je pense que la nationalité
s'hérite ou se mérite
c'est extrêmement simple une personne
qui ne pose aucune difficulté à notre
pays doit pouvoir acquérir bien sûr la
nationalité française
le problème c'est qu'aujourd'hui elle
est donné massivement à des gens qui
dans bien des cas ne la mérite pas c'est
le véritable problème les binationaux
sont français à part entière mais oui
tant que la binationalité existe
disposent ils ont la nationalité
française mois les députés qu'on a
entendu nous un gouvernement considérait
pas comme français non mais n'importe
quoi on considère l'ensemble des
français comme le véritable français ça
me fait aucun doute en revanche il est
vrai que nous proposons de faire en
sorte qu'ils choisissent à un moment
donné parce que nous sommes contre la
binationalité par principe nous
considère pas ce que c'est dangereux
évidemment nous leur poserons la
question de savoir laquelle des deux
nationalités
ils veulent choisir je pense que c'est
utile à la sécurité des français et que
c'est une clarification nécessaire qu'on
a comme on n'a qu'une seule mère on n'a
qu'une seule patrie il y à une
surenchère d'un taux comme ça sur les
questions de sécurité ce que vous êtes
surpris ou satisfait que françois
hollande reprenne une partie des idées
des délais front national sont encore
une fois il ya un certain nombre de
propositions de bon sens qui ont été
faites par le président de la république
et c'est tant mieux
et eux aussi par le premier ministre
mais les déclarations d'intention les
paroles ne sont pas suffisantes il faut
passer maintenant aux actes il faut
réformer la politique pénale
il faut nous ont dit que c'est une
victoire idéologique évidemment écoutez
nous avons dit oui nous avons dit ce qui
est évoquée parfois aujourd'hui par le
gouvernement pendant des dizaines
d'années sous les insultes parfois en
étant menacé de procès et aujourd'hui on
s'aperçoit finalement qu'on est devenus
des gens tout à fait tout à fait
extraordinaire j'espère que les français
vont se rendre compte de la complicité
de l'ensemble de la classe politique
dans ce dossier
à voir ça tout de suite avec la loupe du
scan
james est à vous david rachline on va
reparler un peu des élections régionales
mardi soir vous étiez à toulon pour
assister au meeting de marion
maréchal-le pen qui est candidate en
nationale 1 dans la région paca
alors vous parle il ya quelques secondes
de ce qu'est être français justement
elle a voulu énuméré un peu les critères
qui doivent selon elle respectait les
musulmans pour être considérés à ses
yeux comme français par exemple je cite
se plier aux moeurs et au mode de vie
que l' influence grecque romaine et
seize siècles de chrétienté ont façonné
elle a aussi critiqué ceux qui vivent en
djellaba quel rapport avec les
compétences du conseil régional david
rachline ouais on a parfaitement le
droit dans le cadre d'un meeting
politique de parler de ce dont on a
envie tout à l'heure vous devez y
compris dans les comptes dans le cadre
des ligues ont pris y compris de ce qui
intéresse les français
marc-étienne lansade quelques minutes
avant qui est notre tête de liste dans
le var parler des compétences régionales
de l'économie du développement économie
et marion a fait une analyse que général
vous savez pourquoi
parce que les français attendent des
solutions suite à ce qui s'est passé
dans notre pays et je crois que nous en
importons qu'elle en apporte elle aussi
un certain nombre donc alors ses propos
ils ont quand même pas plu à tout le
monde au sein du front national on est
entendu va le rendre saint-just
notamment qui est candidat front
national en ile de france
il a dit ces propos sont inutiles moi
j'essaye d'embrasser tous les êtres
humains qui habitent sur le sol de la
région que voudrait diriger
ça vous inspire un commentaire de hum ça
malgré ça m'inspire pas de commentaire
particulier si ce n'est que chacun est
libre de porter le message qu'il
souhaite
nous ne sommes pas dans une secte au
front national il ya pas de ligne vers
ce que je peux vous dire en tout cas
c'est que le front national on considère
l'ensemble des français comme des
français à part entière mais il y a
c'est pas parce qu'on a dit ça comme
préalable qu'il faut éviter le débat sur
l'avancée des communautarismes et le
recul de notre république dans un
certain nombre de cas l'avancé de
revendication politico-religieuse qui
essayent de transgresser parfois la loi
de la république
on doit se poser de ces questions on
doit lutter pour davantage
d'assimilation on doit rappeler quelle
est l'identité de notre pays cette
identité nationale qui doit être partagé
en effet marion maréchal-le pen a raison
là dessus par l'ensemble de nos
compatriotes est respecté à minima par
l'ensemble de nos compatriotes il ya des
points de vue différents sens de votre
parti
également sur la question du planning
familial marion maréchal-le pen annoncé
qu'elle supprimerait les subventions au
planning parce que je cite ça apporte
une approche banaliser l'avortement
marine le pen elle n'aide pas du tout
cas d'accord pardon elle dit j'estime
avoir des choses beaucoup plus
importantes à faire elle ne prévoit donc
pas de supprimer les allocs
vous avez choisi votre camp vous david
rachline et le principe est le suivant
chaque candidat s'adresse à aux
habitants de sa région et lui propose un
projet on n'est pas obligé de dupliquer
systématiquement le même projet à la
tension monte en côte il est supprimé
il y à il y à un certain nombre de
situations spécifiques dans nos
territoires qui verront des propositions
économiques en matière formation qui ne
seront pas les mêmes par exemple qui ne
seront pas les mêmes
en paca que dans la région mais alors
vraiment pas conséquent chaque candidat
est libre de faire les propositions
qu'ils souhaitent
je ne crois pas à titre personnel que ce
soit en effet la priorité absolue
mais chacun est libre et chacun chaque
position de chaque candidat doit être
respectée alors un autre élu proche du
fn a fait parler de lui cette semaine il
s'agit de robert ménard il était présent
à toulon aussi à mardi le maire de
béziers a proposé la création d'une
garde biterroise ans je cite encore
sortes de milices composées d'anciens
policiers d'anciens power super à la
police municipale
mais le préfet soit après vous savez il
ya des règles vous savez on est dans un
état de droit
donc si le préfet si l'état lui donne
l'autorisation pour le faire qu'ils le
voteraient facture il ya s'est prononcé
contre je sais ce que j'allais vous dire
le préfet il se trouve que le préfet lui
a écrit pour lui dire qu' il n'était pas
d'accord avec cela
donc il n'y aura pas de garde biterroise
il ya un état de droit la république est
une et indivisible la loi est respectée
le préfet a dit ce qu'il avait quelle
était la position de l'état les choses
sont claires il n'aura pas pas plus que
cette garde maintenance n'évitons pas le
débat qu'est ce qu'il a voulu faire
robert ménard c'est alerter les français
sur la problématique de la sécurité dans
nos communes
parce qu'à force de nous supprimer
des dotations tel qu'ils le font un
million et demi je voulais dit tout à
l'heure dans ma commune eh bien on fait
des investissements ont fait moins
d'investissements qu'avant on ne peut
plus avoir des effectifs suffisants en
termes de polices municipales on manque
de moyens le privé et on fera pas appel
au privé on essaiera d'augmenter les
moyens en tout cas dans nos villes de la
police municipale mais ça n'est pas
évident parce qu'on manque de soutien
financier et l'état là-dessus porte une
grave responsabilité
''j'ai minutes dernière question ne
l'avait pas vu depuis longtemps mais
jean marie le pen a fait son retour
médiatique cette semaine dans une
interview il a appelé à voter pour tous
les candidats front national y compris
florian philippot quand même son ennemi
juré des derniers mois c'est quoi c'est
là la hache de guerre est enterrée entre
20 et le pen et le front ou alors est-ce
que c'est un un appel un peu nécessaire
du père fondateur dans l'est dans les
mouvements politiques il peut y avoir
des difficultés à surmonter
marine le pen avait dit un certain
nombre de désaccords avec jean marie le
pen est là elle a osé le faire avec la
plus grande clarté parce qu'on devait la
clarté aux français maintenant
j'aimerais le pen est un homme
responsable et il sait bien que c'est
pour le front national qu'il faut
derrière le front national qu'il faut
être pour redresser ce pays savent où il
n'est pas le seul d'ailleurs parce
qu'avec lui manifestement il ya 30% des
français savourent la partage cette
analyse
ça vous voilà donc un nouveau
rapprochement entre jean marie le pen
mais écoutez je ne sais pas je ne crois
pas en tout cas juste en tout cas ce qui
est certain c'est que ceux qui veulent
redresser ces régions ceux qui veulent
porter une politique alternative aux
responsabilités ceux qui veulent sortir
des errances de la droite et de la
gauche au pouvoir depuis des dizaines
d'années doivent voter pour le front
national à ces élections régionales je
pense que c'est clair merci ce sera le
mot de la fin david rachline merci
d'avoir été l'invité de parlons à vous
de la semaine prochaine n'oubliez pas de
suivre la soirée électorale sur la
chaîne parlementaire dès 9h30 dimanche
soir